Huge drama happening.
Our good friend
friend of the show
loserbox
was uh
close to talking to me, I think. But
then he's like
I I need I need a good I need a good
faith critique first. So he must look at
something here first and then maybe he
goes back to it, I think. I think. Or is
it earlier?
It's earlier. This is the second part.
So yeah, loserbox is doing this gay
issue. He's like You're being bad faith.
You're being bad faith. It's like so
just queer. I just can't take it.
I can't take it. But we're going to talk
about it. We're going to go over it.
Uh what do I want to say to open this uh
segment? What do I want What do I want
to talk about?
I feel like I should lay some stuff out
first. I feel like I should um
talk about my opinion on the Iran thing.
That's relevant here.
So this this disagreement, guys,
disagreement here
is over loserbox's appearance on
H3 podcast mainly, okay?
He went on there and Ethan is obviously
like pro the strikes, basically.
He's like uh doing everything but saying
this is awesome and I support it.
And the only hesitation that's like
discussed really
is uh it's Trump and Heggseth doing it.
Now, there are some sort of flashes of
other considerations coming through from
loserbox, but certainly not from Ethan.
And
he said loserbox says at one point
Oh, I would try you know
That's probably the biggest problem with
this. So I would support I think I think
he said I think he says he would support
it if it wasn't Trump and Heggseth doing
it.
And basically I'm like, well, that's
[__]
You shouldn't support this just cuz it's
from a Dem.
And then I say
I say that in a very long extended way
where I'm being entertaining for stream.
I'm I'm talking at length and Luna Box
hates that.
And then I say, I don't think Luna Box
actually thinks that. I feel like Luna
Box must think
that the operation would be just
entirely different
under under a different presidential
executive team.
And he would not It's not that he would
support this action from a different
president.
It's that there's some formulation of
the idea of intervening in Iran
that he would support
but just nothing like this.
But at no point
is he actually laying out
what those conditions would be.
And he's not really got a whole lot of
energy for the criticism of this action
because fundamentally he does kind of
just agree with it. Uh so, I guess, you
know,
I'll talk about
when I would think it would be
it would be justified.
Uh obviously the biggest issues
with
the strikes right now, there was no
imminent threat
to Israel or the United States, so
there's no reason for them to strike
using the self-defense
uh
reasoning.
They have not pursued
a UN Security Council resolution
approving use of force.
And
the United States
have not
Congress has not approved it. So, none
of the democratic process or
international process
has been followed.
And that and no there's no imminent
threat.
Now, there are cases
where that's that's not quite those
criteria are not quite fulfilled and
we're still supporting intervention.
The one everyone brings up obviously is
Kosovo
because there was not actually
a UN Security Council resolution
authorizing use of force before the
intervention in Kosovo making it
technically illegal.
However,
that was after it the intervention was
still after like a year
of other resolutions through the UN and
Security Council condemning the
violence, calling for an end, ordering
them to stop,
bringing uh there were like peace these
huge peace talks between
um
Russia and what what was called the
Contact Group, which is like Russia, the
UK, US, France, I think someone else.
Um
that spoke that did negotiations between
the uh the Kosovo Liberation Army or
whatever the [__] it's called and um
and the Yugoslavs.
And basically the KLA
signed up to this deal that would have a
NATO peacekeeping forces in the area to
stop everything and the and the
the Yugoslavs wouldn't. So, basically it
got to the point where the only way
they could intervene
would be with a Security Council
resolution and Russia and China were
likely to veto it.
So, they just had to act.
And it's like, yes, that's illegal,
but the phrase was illegal but
legitimate
because every other option had been
exhausted
and it's just by any metric, any moral
analysis, absolute action had to be
taken.
That's not the case here.
It just simply isn't.
There has been like almost no attempt.
There have been these like show
negotiations recently.
Where the US was clearly
negotiating in bad faith.
I believe, I could be wrong on this. J
Stool told me this, so if this is wrong,
it's his fault.
My understanding is they basically
wanted Iran
to not even have like civilian nuclear
enrichment, like nuclear enrichment for
for uh power.
Uh they wanted them to
basically get the power for the nuclear
stations from America, be totally
dependent.
Which is like even further than the the
JCPOA went.
Like and just totally crazy.
It's always like
you know, if if that's again, I don't
have a 100% true. I haven't fact-checked
it and to be I don't I'm not going to do
it right now.
But like that is a giving over like, you
know, that's basically giving over their
sovereignty of a country, really. If
you're just like saying, "Yeah, I'm
going to be energy reliant on the US.
They have to give me the handouts." So
uh yeah, totally crazy. So So all uh
options have not been exhausted. It's
like totally absurd. So any So here's my
issue, right?
When Lone Wolf says,
"I would support this."
"I would probably support this."
Whatever he said. "I would probably
support this if it weren't Trump and
Hegseth."
It's like, "Yeah, can I imagine a
version of Iran intervention that I
support?" Yes, I can imagine a version
of Iran intervention I support. But to
say you would support this
from anyone else,
there's like almost no aspect of this
that I support. Right?
So only in the sense that there is some
world in which Iran intervention is
justified and a good idea.
Where the timeline proceeding and the
plan following
are like absolutely 100% different to
how they are in reality. Yes, maybe I
would I would support it. But then
you're sort of not really saying
anything.
Then you're really kind of just not
[__] saying anything. You're just
saying you really don't like the
Ayatollah or you think they've done bad
[__] recently that should be stopped.
And it's like, yeah, fair fair enough.
Slaughtering tens of thousands of
protesters is pretty [__] bad.
But they didn't go into Stop I did that.
I didn't let They let that happen. They
said, "Iranian people rise up." And then
gave the regime a month and a half to
slaughter them, systematically track
them down and slaughter them. Yeah,
exactly Orange Blart. It becomes
vacuous. It's like all Lone the Box is
saying is that
he he supports intervention as a
concept.
It's so worthless. Like, what the [__]
are you actually saying?
So, let's see. Maybe Lone the Box lays
out his opinion more clearly and can
have a more
uh uh good faith critique and good faith
critique that Lone the Box wants.
Uh okay, might as well do this slop.
Um
First, you that's Quiman, friend of the
show.
Uh used to rate him quite a bit. Had
some talks.
Not particularly interesting, kind of
restrained. Uh would you call
What the Marine protesting in the Senate
is is
>> they were pretty interesting.
I thought they were pretty interesting
when you were calling
Atheist Zionist despite the fact there's
been a
multi-year long drama that you sucked
his dick off for the entire time it's
entirely built on the fact that people
were quote unquote unfairly calling him
a Zionist.
I thought that was quite an interesting
conversation, personally.
I thought it was an interesting
conversation when you said it was
anti-Semitic to be against Israel as an
ethno-state.
I thought it was quite an interesting
conversation.
But I'm sure those are I'm sure just
saying those things alone is enough to
classify you a bad faith critique, even
though those things literally happened
exactly how I said they did.
Arm broken.
Uh, I haven't seen it, so I don't know.
I just know they got their arm broken.
Okay.
Um, I don't know. Someone sent me this.
I pre-watched a bit of it. Um, it's not
the first time I've seen him kind of
doing little segments on or often
quite often segments that don't go on to
his
uh actual channel segments. Like they
just stay in the stream vod and not many
people see them. Uh, it didn't really
like I I know the kind of pattern he
engages in when he does this. I just
didn't really think it was worth
covering, but I thought um
in the current context it might be
interesting. Uh,
Do you have a chat replay here? I'll be
fine. But what Dude, I even know what
this guy's trying to say. This is the
thing, man. This is one of my pet peeves
of LionA Box.
This guy's got like the same perverted
victim mindset as Destiny, where he
thinks like everyone's out to get him.
It's like the way he's saying that.
So, is this is like stream segments that
like don't end up on the main channel No
one's hiding them, bro.
So, where the [__] do I upload it? I
have a second channel where I do dry
actual politics stuff,
usually doing a proper segment with my
cam on and [__]
And I have my main channel where I do
drama slop [__]
LionA Box coverage doesn't fit neatly
into either.
So, it doesn't get uploaded.
And usually it's not a full segment,
either.
And you see this with him many times.
Like he had a whole thing where he was
like cracking down on Discord splinter
servers. He's like, "I've got to I've
got to do my
Night of the Long Knives on my mod team
and get get rid of the get rid of all
the
snocker splinter Discord servers."
And it's just like it is the
taking [__] way too deep
that see from sadly so many people.
Let's see. Let's see what he has to say
about my uh
thoughts.
It is Lone Coder. You can I mean you can
tell me if you think this guy is like um
good faith critic or not, but
>> It sounds like that's not necessarily
true. When you When you analyze that
>> crazy. I literally can't take it. It
makes me gag. It makes me gag hearing
this F slash say this [__]
Is he a good faith critic? Is he Is he a
good faith critic?
What do you mean by that? I'm saying
what I think.
What does good faith and bad faith mean
other than you say what you think
and don't lie about what the other
person thinks.
That's what I'm doing.
Do I say it in a mean way? Yes.
Do I use personal attacks? Yes.
Is that bad faith?
I wasn't aware it is. I I I was not
aware of that. If that's the case,
I was not aware of it.
My understanding was that this was an
entertainment medium.
And if someone wanted to get dry,
reliable political analysis,
they would read a [__] article.
And my job
was to present my thoughts, opinions,
and information I've collected
in an entertaining way.
Often times inflammatory to attract
attention.
But the moment it's like I get There are
people you can do this with.
Like me and Chud can do this, no
problem.
Me and Jay Stoo can do this, no problem.
Then you get people like Lone a Box and
Nick the Oreo and it's like
They're being hot. They're being bad
faith to me. They're being bad faith to
me. They're being toxic and bad faith to
me.
It's a [__] live stream, dude. It's a
[__] live It doesn't have to be the
end of the world, bro.
It doesn't destroy the criticism that
someone's making personal attacks in
between.
And it shouldn't.
It's the [__] internet.
But I don't want to be like the oh, cod
lobbies, you know, you're on the
internet, bro. I won't do this [__]
[__] but come on. What do Thank you, by
the way, Isabelle.
They don't do banter in Scotland.
everything on the whole.
It doesn't have to be worse. It could be
It could be worse in the sense that one
outcome potentially is the
the Ayatollah's gone, but then there's
the youth of the IRGC who are
[clears throat] easily the most
indoctrinated
>> So, Lone Wolf Box has actually So,
for all the uh go Oh, you're being bad
faith to me. You're being bad faith.
He's actually come in very late on this
segment, I notice.
And I believe we're going to miss out
the part part of this here
where basically I say
that the point that's being made here is
Lone Wolf Box is like
entertaining the idea
that there could be a good outcome,
right?
I might even have to go back and find
it.
But Lone Wolf Box is like, "Yeah, there
could be good outcomes. There could also
be really bad ones." And he's laying out
the bad one here.
But they've missed out the part where
the whole intro into this part of the
conversation is talking about the idea
that oh, this could go well. And you're
about to hear me basically say
there's no reason there is actually no
reason to think this is going to go
well, to think this is going to suddenly
get better. There is no reason to
believe that.
So, let's see. the most radicalized
faction
of the entire Islamic Republic. They're
the youngest generation, and they're
more radical and more
hardline than
>> I'm sorry, but it's already worse. I
don't think it's going to get better and
you're like Loner Box reinforces
negative stereotypes
of our subscribers.
Watching him makes me feel like tripling
my dose, ironically enough.
So, I get the feeling Loner Box get very
personally upset and I am calling him a
[__] but I'm also saying Ethan's a
[__] Ethan is doing more of the
retardation here.
But, Loner Box comes on and Loner Box
says
Yeah, it could it could go well. We
might even pull the quiet up in the
night if this is if this becomes right.
I haven't seen the whole I haven't I
haven't seen any of this Loner Box
reaction yet.
Um but yeah, basically the point here is
you're a you sound like a [__] if
you're entertain seriously entertaining
the idea of like we're heading towards a
free Iran.
If you are seriously entertaining that
possibility right now
you sound [__] I don't think that
should be controversial.
Like this.
Even just to me, it's like clear what's
happening. And it could be the situation
changes.
But, you have there is no evidence that
that is going to be the case. There is
no reason there is nothing we're being
shown right now
that should lead you towards thinking
that.
Trump is saying
the Shah is not fit.
It should be someone inside the country.
That's what Trump has said.
They've also indicated they might want
someone from the existing regime. They
said they had guys they wanted to or or
looking at taking over.
Israel's uh
objectives obviously do not line up with
Iran
being like a free, prosperous
democratic nation. They line up with
Iran being
a balkanized, ruined
failed state that can never hope to
accumulate the
economic power
to fund a nuclear program.
So, there is nothing you're
we're looking at right now that
indicates, "Oh, this is going to
suddenly get better and result in a free
Iran."
So, to present it as a possibility, to
sit there and do the fan fic about it,
the theorizing this is going to happen,
it does make you look [__]
happen here.
The US is already The US and Israel
already destabilized the country and the
regime with the initial strikes on
Fordow and all that [__] earlier.
Uh 6 months ago, whenever.
That already weakened the regime.
There's been a swelling of support
for an opposition,
partly
due to American and Israeli interference
and incitement.
US
state officials, former state officials
This is even a bad example for me to
spin. It's like the Pompeo [__] about
the Mossad marching with uh
protesters. Like that's true. He did say
that [__]
But Trump was out there tweeting and
posting on Truth Social like on January
13th or some [__] like, "Raise up
Iranian people. Raise up Raise up and
take your country."
Like they were they were literally
outright just they were inciting
as if they were going to help. And
they're say He's like saying like, "Oh,
yeah. I Don't Don't kill the
protesters." I told And they do nothing.
They do nothing to stop it for weeks.
officials
are saying say openly Was it Huckabee, I
think, or Pompeo? One of them.
said openly,
"Good luck to all the Iranian protesters
and all of the Mossad agents." Sorry,
guys. I had to step away for uh a drink.
Literally 2 seconds. I'm just going to
leave this paused cuz I don't want to
miss anything Land of the Blind says.
Okay? So, just 1 second. Okay, I'm back.
marching alongside them.
They say this openly. They have fomented
the resistance, the opposition.
>> How does that even work? So, first of
all, I I don't know if he's forgotten,
but you know Iran deals with urban
uprisings or protest uprisings like all
the time. Like every few years they're
having to go through another round of
quelling and murdering protesters in the
hundreds. Uh even before the there was
the hijab protests in 2022. I think
before that there was whatever one where
they ended up massacring like 500 people
there 2009.
Literally, Commodore Trump, that is an
easy
30 minutes at least. When I literally
said, "I'm going AFK for 1 minute."
[__] [__] in was one before that
where they were trying to where they
were still trying to hold on to this
idea of reformism, which has obviously
completely died now cuz the reformists
have been in power for a good while at
least in the presidency and they haven't
really delivered.
Um
What what are we saying here? The The
protesters don't necessarily need a push
from
Yeah.
My point is that when you push, which
America and Israel did,
you in some way almost incur part of the
responsibility, you know? If you're
going to go out there and say, "Come on
Come on Iranian people. Rise up. Rise
up. Ayatollah, don't you dare kill them.
Don't you dare Oh, it's going to be real
bad for you if you kill them."
And then you let them all die. You've
incurred some responsibility for that.
That's the point.
From Do they Like how much of a push do
you think Mossad are giving them?
Yeah.
It's not to say that the Iranian
revolution Iranian opposition
is manufactured, fake. It's not to say
they don't really think it and Mossad
have just come over and
made a made a fake revolution. No one's
saying that.
No one's saying that.
About the responsibility that the US and
Israel incur for encouraging behavior
that benefited them, led to the deaths
of those people, and they did nothing
about it. They have incited
>> Also, I am That's just I don't know why
he's pretending to understand like the
complexities of somewhere like Iran, but
um
that's just I don't know why he's saying
that. Like I don't I don't I don't
[laughter] I don't know why you're
pretending to pretend to understand
anything. Like, can this guy do anything
without the [__] smarmy,
smarmy
Like, he sounds like a leftist.
And if you read books? Do you read
books? It's like, give it a [__]
rest, bro.
Give it a [__] rest.
If I don't understand something, then
point out where the gap in my
understanding is.
But if you're not contesting the
conclusion or the argument in any
reasonable way,
then it seems like I understand
perfectly well enough to make the claims
I'm making. Is that like mental to think
that there is not
at least one outcome of this that could
actually be better for Iran? It's not
like it would be the first ever US
intervention uh in a country where the
regime is already insanely unpopular
that didn't result in something better.
That's Obviously, it's unstable now. But
what
What [__] point is he making here?
to think that there That's just I don't
know why he's pretending to understand
like the complexities of somewhere like
Iran, but um
that's just I don't know why he's saying
that. Like, is that mental to think that
there is not
at least one outcome of this that could
actually be better for Iran? It's not
like it would be the first ever US
intervention
uh in a country where the
Well, yeah, Loner Box. No one's saying
there's not a theoretically, logically
possible outcome that could be better
for Iran. Yes, Loner Box. If I If I had
sit here Doctor Strange timeline
analysis,
yes, there is at least one.
There is at least one
where it's better for Iran. I would say
I would say that, Loner Box, yeah.
What a [__] stupid, vacuous point to
make, seriously. What a [__] stupid
vacuous point to make.
Obviously what I'm saying is there is no
uh like reasonable evidence.
Evidence that would reasonably lead you
to the conclusion that it's going to be
better for Iran or it's likely to be
better for Iran. That that's a likely
outcome. That's a plausible outcome.
You know, it it may be logically
possible, but I don't see it as
particularly plausible, okay?
To borrow from Pisco.
Yeah, I I I just thought that's totally
reasonable.
And then Lion of the Box is like, "Oh,
you really think there's no no world
where it could possibly No, I I see that
it could possibly.
I just don't think that's going to
happen. I think you sound like a [__]
sitting there going,
"Oh, well, maybe it there's one world
where this would actually turn out
great. Here's how Bernie can still win."
Regime is already insanely un
>> It's like you sound like you always
sound [__] doing this stuff. Make
your analysis based on what is
reasonable, likely, plausible.
Not what's possible. Not what you think
might be possible. It's like the same
stupid [__] that [__] Jew Tube idiot
[__] Persians doing on Jay Smooth
Stream the other night. Going like, "Oh,
yeah, but don't you think it's it's
possible that Raisi probably could just
like walk in and take over?"
popular that didn't result in something
better. That's obviously it's unstable
now cuz there's still a war going on.
Uh
I think even in this show, didn't I say
that like I'm even saying here that one
of these outcomes is that the IRGC youth
takes over and they are worse than
>> Yeah, unfortunately Lion of the Box,
you've cut off the start of the segment.
So, you actually don't know what I'm
saying here.
So, that's unfortunate, Lion of the Box.
>> That's probably even that's probably the
most likely outcome. I have no idea what
the is happening with how many defectors
they think they have or what the regular
army's going to do. But to suggest that
like
>> Very bad faith critique from Lion of the
Box. I'm still willing to talk to him,
though.
can only
uh get worse. I I don't know what um
You're a total pervert if you say this
bad faith [__] by the way. Literally,
we're just shaming people for this now.
You You're literally a [__] pervert
if you say this [__]
>> particular piece of information he's
sitting on that makes him so sure of
that, but okay.
They have encouraged it.
They have led the Iranian people up to
the precipice
and then allowed tens of thousands of
them to be slaughtered at the hands of
the
Islamic regime.
And then after
>> Remember, the protesters were already
out en masse
before Trump said help is on the way.
Help is on the The Trump thing was
disgusting. We've talked about that a
billion times, but
the he's Yeah, I I was Yeah, I'm not
saying
the whole protest was Trump or the whole
protest was Mossad. I'm saying that when
you encourage and incite, you incur some
responsibility.
It's disgusting that you then go and
leave those people to die.
out en masse. They were still out en
masse. They were still
there was still going to be that
crackdown. I don't
Responding to a clip, Jim. Awful stuff.
Well, he's not responding to a clip,
Jim. What's actually happened is he's
been seething over this vod offline.
He's pre-watched it and hasn't found the
start again cuz he was midway through
it.
Um
and that's why he's covering it on
stream because much like his Discord
Splinter service, he just can't stop
thinking about it.
[__] You that?
They have illegally bombed all of their
leaders
with no plan for a replacement
leaving the country destabilized and
rudderless
lashing out at other countries around
them
drawing attention, drawing aggro.
Is he blaming the Israel and the US for
the regime killing their own.
Um I mean if I was
if I was being bad faith or if I was
jumping to conclusions or
If you are a [__] [__] it's it's
not a matter of being bad faith or
jumping to conclusions. If you are a
[__] [__]
because even if you were being bad
faith, you would have to be [__]
[__] to try to pass it off as what
I'm saying here when it's clearly not.
>> If I was trying to avoid being looking
for a better explanation, then we would
sound like that, but I don't know.
It's already worse.
>> But I don't know why you're saying it's
already worse. What? Because they
murdered
maybe upwards of 10,000 of their own
people. I don't know why that's saying
that's cuz that's not like Trump takes
responsibility for emboldening
protesters who were already on the
street. I don't know how Trump takes
responsibility
for
I don't know how Trump takes
responsibility for
the regime killing them or for the
protesters starting in the first place.
>> So you don't take responsibility for the
regime killing them, nor do you take
responsibility for them starting.
You take responsibility for your
actions, which is encouraging them and
promising help
and then not delivering when they get
killed.
That's what they have responsibility
for. Hope that helps. Hope that helps. I
understand what he looks like. I guess
he's had a severe head injury recently.
Struggling with this one.
But yeah, you have responsibility for
your actions.
I don't know how that works.
Already gotten tens of thousands of
people killed.
If you were going to do this
act with a plan
Yeah.
>> decisively Yeah. and help the Iranian
people. Isn't that my position that I
articulate in this? What they have done
is No, no, Luna Oi actually does barely
articulate a position at all.
He sits there desperately trying not to
offend Ethan Klein for the entire time,
like every time he goes on there to tap
dance like a [__]
house, you know.
You actually didn't lay out much of a
[__] opinion at all, Lionarbox. You
never do on that show.
Sold them out. They have just sold them
out, and it is so obvious. It's so
obvious to anyone with [__] eyes.
But Lionarbox regardless, anyway, it's
not even just about the plan.
It's not even just about the plan. I'm
saying that if you wanted to do this
successfully, right?
That's what I'm saying there, right?
I'm not saying
this would be justified just with that.
Cuz this is what my concern is, is that
Lionarbox's position
and this is this is like
the good faith version, the ultra good
faith version of the thing he's going to
call bad faith in a bit, okay, at the
end of the segment.
I think at the end of the segment.
Um
the the idea that if it was Trump and
Hexet, if it wasn't Trump and Hexet
doing it, he would support it.
And my concern, my worry, the thing I'm
really condemning from Lionarbox here,
is the idea that he would support them
doing roughly this as long as it was
done well.
I wouldn't support that because they
have not exhausted
uh the available
international options.
They have not been through the Security
Council. There's been no like
uh uh statements on stopping the
violence on protecting the protesters or
anything from the from the UN Security
Council.
It hasn't gone to Congress.
There's just not been any effort to
justify it whatsoever.
And my concern is based on things I've
heard Lionarbox say and defend in the
past
is that he basically just thinks it's
fine to just go around doing these
decapitation strikes
without really putting it to
the international community.
He seemed to support in Doha.
Looks goes on H3
and says
No, this isn't like failures and uh it
could still be good. Potentially is the
uh the Ayatollah's gone, but then
there's
the youth of the IRGC who are
[clears throat]
easily the most indoctrinated, most
radicalized faction
of the entire Islamic Republic. They're
the youngest generation and they're more
radical and more
um hardline than the first the than the
first Ayatollah, than the second, than
anything. Uh and that's actually partly
why they've managed to it was quite easy
for them to crack down on protesters
because these young uh security officers
are just very, very willing to do
whatever it takes to keep the regime in
power.
Uh there is a chance that they survive
the air strikes to a degree that they
can uh
that they they can establish some kind
of military dictatorship over Iran,
which is worse than what we currently
have. But, there's also it could also go
particularly well, right? You could have
defectors from the army and from
>> we go. So, literally like he was like
I'm I'm literally saying here how it's
going to be worse. And it's like, it
could also go better. It could also go
better.
Yeah, there's like no reason to think
that's the case though.
the Basij, like the security forces. You
could have protesters who are able to
overwhelm
>> I do wonder actually, is he trying to
say that the protests were inspired just
because of the 12-day war because that
exposed the regime and showed their
weaknesses. Is that the That's what he
said earlier, right? That doesn't even
make as much sense either though because
again No, no, no, no. I'm obviously I
think that played into it. I think it'd
be crazy to say it didn't play into it.
But, obviously it's not just because of
the [__] 12-day war or just because
of Trump.
But, all these things all these are
factors, no? Is that [__] crazy to
say?
I think I think that's totally
reasonable. Obviously, yeah, the strikes
last year.
Uh was it last year or was it
When was it? I don't even know. It
wasn't last year, was it?
No, it was earlier this year. Dude, I'm
losing track of time.
Um
Or was it last year? 11 months ago.
Jesus.
Six months ago? I'm I've lost track of
time, dude. I've lost track of time.
Anyway, yeah, I think obviously that
played a role.
I do think that played a role. I do
think making the regime look weak
is going to make
the the opposition population more
likely to rise up. I don't think that's
controversial. I don't think it's crazy
to say.
Uh the economic uh crisis that happened
in Iran is largely being attributed
there to the uh snapback sanctions. But
the snapback sanctions were Well, yeah,
yeah. And the sanctions have created
conditions that are like unlivable.
Well, not like totally unlivable. We I
mean, like pretty bad conditions for the
average person. That makes them more
discontent with the government as well.
There's a lot of reasons, I'm sure.
There's a lot of reasons. There's a lot
of factors here.
But I'm making the statement. I'm not
making the statement that any of these
are determinative.
I am saying that Trump holds
responsibility and the US and Israel and
the Shah hold responsibility for egging
those protesters on with the promise of
help and not delivering.
That played into them getting killed.
If they had helped, they may not have
been killed. Now, even though I don't
know that help at that point would have
been justified, but hey, that that would
have been better.
seemingly going to get imposed one way
or the other because they weren't
imposed by
um
they weren't imposed by America. The
snapbacks came from the European powers
cuz the European powers, uh France,
Germany, the UK, they were still part of
the JCPOA. And when it became very clear
that the IAEA was seeing very very
[__] behavior from Iran with the 60%
nuclear enrichment, when they were when
they were seeing that, they
they instigated the snapback the
snapback sanctions
because
they were about to expire anyway. So
they but they they saw plenty of
violations on their end. Like the JCPOA
still did exist. It's just that America
wasn't part of it anymore.
So I don't know if we're going to blame
them for it. Are we going to blame our
own country and France and Germany
because those were the new sanctions
that came in between the 12 day
>> about blame. Like what is
what is this [__] [__] saying? Does
he think I'm like
bigging up the Iranian regime? Does he
think I'm like pro IRGC or something?
What what do you think's going on here?
Do you think I'm saying
oh, the Iranian people would love the
Ayatollah if it weren't for these
Western powers putting sanctions and
making them manipulating them against
Islam?
You think that's what I'm saying, Lone
Wolf? You some kind of [__] [__]
or into that? We're going to blame them
for destabilizing Iran?
And I don't know if he's suggesting that
they should have maybe got involved when
the protesters were actually out there
in full and before the firing happened.
But then the issue there is they didn't
have the means. That you you know how
Trump had to like how America was
deploying all of that [__] over to the
Middle East in the past few weeks before
the strike. So you can say it was No, my
position is not that they should have
done it then. They shouldn't have done
it at all. They should have gone through
the proper channels. They should have
made attempts to pursue [__] through the
UN Security Council. They should have
gone through Congress.
But it would have been better
to act earlier.
It would have been better.
And if you can't act, then don't say you
will.
missed opportunity Like this is
I feel like none of this is remotely
controversial. No?
If you can't stop, if you do not have
the military hardware in position to
stop the regime from killing the
protesters, then do not make tweets and
speeches where you say
if you kill the protesters, I'm going to
use military hardware to stop you.
If you can't do that for another month.
Like again, there's so many aspects here
where it's just totally wrong. It's
totally wrong. It's totally morally
repugnant.
I don't know what it's like, what can
you do? What can you do? Are you really
saying they shouldn't do this? Yeah.
Yeah, I am actually. Yeah, that's what
I'm saying. I'm saying they shouldn't do
it. But it's quite questionable how much
they could have done to help at that
time as well, which is why Trump
tweeting that thing out was so [__]
negligent and so destructive.
>> Okay, I guess he guess he's just saying
he's just saying he agrees with me?
Yes, it was disgusting. Yes, that's what
I'm saying. And then saying help is on
the way when it turned out the only help
he was referring to was some people were
maybe against Starlink. Like that's
that's the only thing they seem to have
done.
Government buildings that have been or
the government positions that have been
weakened, and you can actually have Reza
Pahlavi coming in and his plan working.
It's it's a very
If it were any other president, I would
completely support it because
>> Saying Hezbollah is not anti-Semitic,
but there is Mhm. You know, it's
basically the same as taqiyya.
You know?
There's a lot of just [__] retards
that are just saying it to mean
you're lying.
It's like, why are you using a special
word
for Jews lying or Muslims lying?
You know?
It's
It's [clears throat] hard to It's hard
to overestimate just how bad the current
state of affairs is.
>> I I just I don't know what what kind of
like what disco what what ideology we
have going on here. I mean, I can say
when my brain would say tankie, but like
he actually preferred Pahlavi. If you
think Pahlavi would be worse than the
current regime, you are [__]
[__] You know nothing. If you think
even the current regime is anything on
the same If you think the Shah, the
actual like the big body dictator Shah,
if you think even he was anything
>> out over
Goon Squad
with the Tom Foolery profile picture.
I feel like this is this comes up this
exudes a lack of confidence. I almost
don't care about the political opinions
in my chat.
Because I know like, you know,
either I'm right and everyone's going to
come around to me anyway, or you know,
I'll I'll just adjust little bits where
I'm where I miss.
You know, it just I it doesn't I like
don't give a I could not give a [__] if
some [__] thinks that the Shah would
be worse than the Ayatollah. Like
obviously I don't agree with that.
I think the Ayatollah is particularly
bad.
But I I don't think the Shah's like
great.
I'm not like a huge fan of Reza Pahlavi.
But there aren't any good options,
really. It's like
the Ayatollah or the
uh the IRGC or
or uh
Reza Pahlavi
or the MEK.
You were near as bad as the regime. You
You know nothing. You know the I'm
sorry, you just know you don't know
anything, okay? The Shah, for all his uh
brutality and killing political
opponents and everything, the Islamic
Republic outdid him within months. They
Within months, they set up tribunals for
their political opponents and were
executing more people within like a year
or two than the Shah had in his entire
uh couple of decades rule. Like [__]
hell.
He actually preferred Pahlavi. You Of
course, you [__] idiot. You Right.
And people talk about destabilizing.
What [clears throat] is it Was Was Iran
stable when they murdered at least 7,000
of their own people in 3 days? Like no,
not really. I mean, what what is stable
here?
>> Yeah, like is that [__] for Indians?
>> At some point, there does kind of need
to be a change. So,
it's just a very real shame that you've
got Trump and Hegseth leading the charge
right now. That's a good point, yeah.
They're kind of the least competent.
>> [snorts]
>> Most cynical. Is that what Lionel Box
does this? Oh, what ideology is going on
in your chat? What ideology How have you
got all these snarky tankies in your in
your chat?
And so, you go to a you go to Lionel
Box's chat or Discord, and it's like
Yeah, the thing about Palestinians,
they're all a bunch of
I can't even say it, bro. Living in
bombed-out sewage, living in mud huts,
in bombed-out sewage, and they just
can't stop [__] killing people.
You give them a toilet, they give them
you give them indoor plumbing, they dig
it all up to shoot rockets over the
[__] border.
We just
a mole. We just [__] a mole. That's
like and that's like the Lionel Box
audience.
President, you could have to do it.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um this is a video, by the way, of when
the news hit Iran that
the Ayatollah was was killed, just to
give you an idea.
Like you are just shilling for the
strikes.
>> Also, by the way,
guys, tell me tell me when tell me when
Destiny goes online, so I can start
watching Lionel Box. Someone tells me
when I'm when my favorite Someone tell
me when my favorite streamer goes
online, so I can tune out of Lionel Box.
So, yeah, you're just shilling for the
strikes.
Is he talking to the Iranians or or to
Ethan? Like what should Should people
just not show this?
Is this just irrelevant information?
That's like universal re- rejoicing.
There's [snorts] like if you were afraid
that there was people that dis- a lot of
people that disagreed with you, Well,
no, obviously I'm aware selling it with
the US selling out or something.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you, huge appreciate. Thank you so
much.
Um I'm sorry. Retards in every country
support stupid [__] all the time. It
doesn't mean that shit's getting better
or it was a good idea.
We were afraid
that there was people that dis- a lot of
people that disagreed with you. Well,
no. Obviously, I'm aware. Selling it
with the US selling out insurgent groups
in the Middle East is incredibly common.
I'm aware.
But isn't just like the the group is
it's like the people. It's like 80% of
this population want their government
gone. Wanted the regime to fall.
They had these mass protests.
And then tens of thousands of them
were slaughtered.
And you sat there and watched.
You made these gay warnings saying, "Oh,
if you if you kill those people, we're
going to do something. We'll stop you."
Did nothing.
Watched them get slaughtered. And then
when the resistance is crushed,
then you kill the leader.
Then you kill the leader. And people are
defending it.
Is this argument that they just came in
too late?
No.
No. But the way it was done is
particularly egregious. No, that's not
my problem. It's not that it was just
too late. No, there are a million other
problems with that with it before you
even get to the too late part.
I am describing why this is particularly
abhorrent.
And yet, never lays out an opinion.
Never lays out an Oh, does he really
think? Does he really think?
Does he really think?
Say something, man. Say something.
Like you you would support it if he did
it during the protests?
Remember, the protests had resumed. So,
if that's his position, the protests had
resumed
like 5 days before the
before these strikes. Yeah, well, after
they've had like [__] 40,000 of them
[__] killed, yes.
Dude, it's not just about the protests.
It's not just about the protests.
Obviously, part of protest is having
organized groups like you have groups
organizing those protests.
And a lot of the people that are likely
to have died
in that month-long gap,
in that 40,000, are going to be people
that are attracting the most attention
on the front lines of the protests, I
would imagine, if they get gunned down.
And they probably try to track
organizers down, too.
So, a key So, a key part of this is not
just that there are people out in the
streets, it's that the the organizers,
the people that would be pushing and and
making the effort, the the ones that put
their head above the parapet the most,
have now been killed.
So, it makes it infinitely harder
for a successful
overthrow attempt.
Students were back out again, but
Ethan's saying like, "Oh, look how happy
the people are."
>> I don't even think me or Ethan are
defending it. Where are we going to get
this from?
>> is literally the whole way through like,
"Oh, well, you know, it's not that bad,
is it?"
Wow, great. Wow, great. Yeah, it means
so much, man. It means so much when
their entire [__] organization has
been like what Ethan bringing this clip
up. Why is Ethan bringing the clip up?
Ask yourself that.
Ethan Ethan isn't defending it. Why is
this clip being brought up? This is
unironically more dishonest and
manipulative than Hasan trying to
pretend he didn't shock his dog.
Weaponized incredulity BPD coded.
>> I hate even that drama being brought up
from the other side. I just don't want
to [__] hear about Hasan shocking his
dog. Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
Crushed. Everyone that, you know,
had any role in the [__] protests
has been [__] slaughtered in the
streets.
Protesters who are able to overwhelm
government buildings that have been or
the government positions that have been
weakened and you can actually have
Hezbollah be coming in and this plan
working. Is this a very
If it were any other president, I would
completely support it because Right.
it's
hard to it's hard to overestimate just
how bad the current state of affairs is,
right? And people don't What do you mean
if it was any other president you would
support it?
Any other I I So I think it's obvious
what I'm saying there, right? I think
what I'm saying
is that the overall
principle, the overall like uh
idea
of you give air support to protesters
who were out before the air strike
started, by the way. You give air
support to the protesters, you take out
the regime, you take out their ballistic
missiles, their nuclear threat, their
um the
>> So literally with
the process followed beforehand. Right,
Lone the Box?
With a with like a UN Security Council
resolution, preferably.
With like congressional approval,
preferably. Right, Lone the Box, right?
Right?
I just see security forces and then that
allows the protesters to step in the
space and uh reclaim their freedom. Like
that's the whole gist of the idea.
Um and if any other president were we're
going to make that decision, they would
absolutely be weighing up questions like
uh are there enough defectors that we
know
>> So literally so he is espousing it it's
like unless it changes in the next few
seconds, it seems like he is espousing
the [__] position that I'm saying is
disgusting and he's calling me bad faith
for saying that he's thinking that.
No, you have the [__] position. You
have the disgusting position which is I
would support war crimes if they were
done competently.
Just do them well. That's what that's
what you're
Yeah, I'm fine with the illegal strike
on this country. Just do it competently.
And you know, obviously, like I've said
earlier, like I laid out earlier, there
are edge cases once all other options
have been exhausted and you're in a
corner and it is the humanitarian
thought out plan thing to do.
To to intervene. There are cases where
something could be illegal and you still
take action. Kosovo obviously being the
example.
But we're not there. We're not there and
you're not laying out those
prerequisites. You're not laying those
out in as necessary for your opinion as
for your support.
You seem to pretty clearly be saying no,
you're fine with the US head of state
basically unilaterally deciding.
Obviously, you know, he thinks there
would be more consultation and weighing
of the options, but essentially
unilaterally deciding uh yeah, we're
going to war with Iran. I'm striking
Iran because I think this regime's
really bad.
Without consulting
you know, the international community,
without going through the UN.
Which is literally That is the
disgusting position that I'm condemning.
So, if that's what you think
yes, I think that you have a very
disgusting position on this
and you should be treated like a Nazi.
You should be like, you know, you like I
say, like the German citizen that goes
along with it.
Because the US is the great Satan.
And if you're playing
defense, you're you're filth.
about within the military or the IRGC to
do this.
Um are the protesters like in a position
where they can actually have some level
of coordination? Is Reza Pahlavi's uh
promise of 50,000 defectors actually
even [__] real? Um
what are the ramifications for the rest
of the Gulf region? What's it going to
do with with regards to what happens to
Israel and Hezbollah? Because obviously
the rest of the axis are going to want
to respond in some way. Are they going
to respond in a forceful way or or in a
kind of pathetic way? It's going to
matter.
Um there are all these questions that I
don't I obviously are they going to
justify it to the people? Are they going
to go to the Congress? Are they going to
go to the European powers and explain
their plan and everything so that it's
got like stages of approval? But
obviously they haven't, which means that
like I don't it's hard to tell if this
was executed on good grounds or just on
nothing on just Trump seeing a price.
>> the thing, he's not stating those as
pretty firm prerequisites. Obviously
like he playing out of like I have to
carry out this every single time. Kosovo
there is a there are carve outs.
But he is not saying that's like a
prerequisite. He's saying like that
would be like a good idea, but based on
everything I've heard him say it does
seem like he's fine with like these
unilateral decapitation strikes.
eyes and just chasing it like a [__]
child like
like a fascist murdering child like
that's that's kind of what I'm saying.
I think that's quite clear.
No, it's not. You just say cuz line of
box all you say is I would probably be
in favor of this if it wasn't Trump and
Hogsett doing it.
That's actually not very clear line of
box.
That's actually not very clear. Even
here you're not particularly clear.
You're not actually laying out like firm
criteria.
You're like leaving room.
You're like saying, "Yeah, another
person would probably do that."
You're not saying, "I would not support
it unless that had happened."
That that's like the firm position that
we're looking for here line of box. I do
not support these attacks because they
are illegal
and no uh
not all other options have been explored
and there was no imminent threat. But
it's like very clear. You can very
clearly lay out a firm position. Why do
people struggle with this, man? Yeah,
Hutch does, too.
Why do people struggle so much with
laying out
"This is what I think. I think this is
wrong because X.
I would think it was right if Y."
Can we can we can we manage that? Can we
manage that? Oh, "I it probably be in
favor if it was if it weren't one of the
hexes doing it.
Not very clear, is it? Really.
I agree in the sense that any other
president would not have done it like
this.
No other president would have done it
this [__]
>> Yeah, obviously.
But why are you shouting at me? Not even
Bush was this dumb, you know?
I agree in that sense. Mhm.
Okay.
But the idea that if you take roughly
what has happened here, you Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I've already I I replayed this when I
was first watching it off stream like
five times just to make sure I knew what
I was listening to.
Um done it like this.
As it is, right? It's
It's hard to It's hard to
I would completely
>> Why why are you yelling? Uh because I'm
projecting my voice and making it
bombastic and entertaining for an
audience so I'm going to watch rather
than sitting there and going
Oh, yeah, it's I suppose like lefties
need to learn how to read books. I
suppose like lefties need to learn how
to
read books.
Lefties need to like learn how to read
books. My entire stream.
I'll be coming in and this plan working.
It's It's a very
Ah.
The thing about comparisons is
that people say
one thing like another, but it's not
exactly the same.
Make me really upset.
If it were any other president, I would
completely support it because Right.
It's
It's hard to It's hard to overestimate
just how bad the current state of
affairs is, right? And people talk
>> What you mean if it was any other
president you would support it?
Any other I agree in the sense that any
other president would not have done it
like this.
No other president would have done it
this [__] Not even Bush was this
dumb, you know?
I agree in that sense.
But the idea that if you take roughly
what has happened here, you would
support it from a different president.
No, this is disgusting.
What do you mean by that? Roughly from a
different president, like Yeah, yeah.
So, if you take roughly the actions that
occurred here,
as in
a unilateral decapitation strike
that hasn't gone through Congress or the
UN
and was not
you know, done in coordination with our
allies
and weeks late
with no on the ground like uh force
ready to take power from the regime.
Yeah, if you take roughly that and put
it on another president, even if it was
done slightly more competently,
that would still be terrible.
That would still be terrible cuz it's
missing key elements
of
you know, that that are necessary for
support.
It it it
It sounds like you're suggesting that I
would support the exact same actions
with the same level of calculation, with
the same consideration of international
ramifications, just if you put a D next
to it?
It That Yes, Lone Wolf. When you say
I would support this if it wasn't Trump
and Hegseth doing it,
well, what you've just said is obviously
an extreme
hyper-specific version.
Yes, that is roughly what what I'm going
to take.
Yes, you would roughly these strikes
from a different president,
you would support.
I would support it if it was anyone
else. Right Yes, I think roughly the
thing that happened here, you're saying,
you would support done by someone else.
Yes.
So, it's just like it is Is it necessary
to Lone Wolf
that all other options have been
exhausted, that you've gone through the
UN Security Council,
you've hit that road block of
China and Russia veto.
Is going to Congress just going to
Congress necessary? Are these necessary?
That's the question. Really it's being
asked a lot. Cuz then it's totally
different. It's a whole different thing.
It's a whole different thing. It's like
a whole different strike.
If it's not unilateral,
if it's months of planning and
discussion with the with the public and
the international community beforehand,
it's like not the same thing at that
point. You're not supporting the same
thing from a different president at
point. And then what you said would be
wrong. It's not actually what you think.
The same behavior with Congress, the
same behavior with European allies? What
the [__] man? What is this? What am I
watching? What is this good faith
[__] principled critique from our boy
here? What the [__] This is disgusting.
Well, wait. So,
responding to him He says, "I would
support this from anyone else."
And I take that to mean
So someone else doing roughly these
actions you would be in favor of.
That's bad faith.
That's bad faith, guys.
How could you possibly lie and smear
Luna box like that? Lie about and smear
Luna box like that?
How could you possibly do that?
Taking his words to mean
the exact literal meaning of the
sentence
with no real room for other
interpretations.
Cuz I I don't say that I would agree
with your position that this is that he
thinks that I say
I would agree with his position that I
would support this from any other
president.
No, I'm saying I agree it would have
been done better.
But I'm I don't agree that you would
support that you should support roughly
these actions
from any other president.
And now he's just going to angrily agree
with me for 5 minutes. is involvement.
Uh but where was any
consultation with the international
community?
Uh no. If you were to support this
action from another president, you are
scum. You are filth.
You are just Like yeah, cuz I would say
I would if it were another president,
yeah. If Biden just did the exact same
thing, but just cuz it's Biden doing it
>> just roughly the same thing. We're
saying
the same action. That's what you're
saying. Well, that's what you're That's
what you're said in the in the clip.
Maybe you don't think that. Maybe you
don't believe that.
You said the same thing. So, we're
talking about a unilateral decapitation
strike.
They decided, America decided,
we want to intervene. We're going to go
do it.
Even if it was done well, still bad.
make me happier. Like are you Do you
seriously think that's my position?
Is that what you think of me? What the
[__] man?
>> Yes, that's what I think roughly your
position is generally, yeah.
I could be wrong.
But based on the other
attacks that I've seen him talk about,
that seems to be where he's at. Like he
doesn't really believe in international
law.
He's like a
ends justify the means on foreign
policy.
That seems That seems to be the case.
Like some subhuman drone,
frankly, to steal a term from Haz, to
steal a term from Charm Hole,
>> Okay, now I have seen this, but I have
rewatched this bit.
He doesn't like this, guys. He doesn't
like this. Come on.
Like some subhuman drone,
frankly, to steal a term from Haz, to
steal a term from Charm Hole, a liberal
fascist.
You are just a degenerate
>> Yeah. Westoid
What does this have to do with fascism?
megalomaniac
who thinks you can go around the globe
execute so
>> point that that I'm making the idea that
you've decided essentially there's this
group like you know essentially the
whole of the Middle East that you can
subjugate and punish
and exploit.
And you don't even have to consult even
your own people about it.
You know, you you do it unilaterally.
You do it as a
as a as a
you know, authority to figure.
>> My man Queenman back at the top of his
game. Loner brings out your best.
>> Megalomanical, megalomanical,
megalomanical. Lebanon loves you.
Thank you for the doner. Huge
appreciate. Thank you so much.
Yo, is that a big doner? Did I just talk
over it?
Significant doner. I can [__] I did.
Wow, $80
from Malash.
Let's play that doner again. I spoke
over it.
Huge appreciate. Insanely generous of
you.
Wait, can I not play it again? There we
go.
My man Queenman back at the top of his
game. Loner brings out your best. Keep
doing what you're doing, brother.
Lebanon loves you. Thank you. Thank you.
Huge appreciate. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Shooting people.
Meddling other people's countries
without ever without even consulting
your own people who paid for the [__]
bomb jets.
>> he's just completely riffing on it now.
He's just he's just taking that to be
like I support
>> Yes, I am riffing. Yes. Yes, it's a
[__] live stream. Yes, I'm riffing.
think about how Trump has done this.
Just that it's not it should be what it
should be a different face. It should
just have a D next to it. That's what
he's doing right now. And I know full
[__] well he doesn't believe that.
That's why he started saying, "Oh yeah,
I agree that a different president would
have done it
I do that is basically how I'm taking
the statement. No, I don't think you
would support literally this exact
action with a D next to it. I think, the
way I'm reading that statement and the
way I still kind of read that statement
based on the way you're speaking here,
is roughly these actions
from a different president, from a
Democratic president, you would support.
So, it it doesn't matter if they've gone
I don't think to learn the box it
matters, and I could be wrong, like I
say,
I don't think it's necessary they go
through the UN first to learn the box. I
don't think it's necessary they go to
Congress first.
I think to learn the box he is generally
ends justify the means, and if this had
been done in a more competent and
planned way,
with with a day after plan and
everything, he would he would be in
favor of it. That's what I think. That's
what I That's what I think. Should be
totally clear,
totally clear, cuz I get frustrated with
learn the box not laying out his
opinion.
That is
clear as day my opinion, okay? So, if
learn the box doesn't think that's how
he thinks, he can just say,
"I don't think that. It is absolutely
necessary to me that they go through the
international community and Congress.
All other options must be exhausted
before you
do something like this."
Definitely, they would have weighed the
pros and cons differently. They would
have consulted Congress, and they would
have informed their European allies, and
they would have had a much better grasp
of what the potential outcomes are. And
if it
>> he's saying informed European allies.
So, all right, informing European
allies, you go through the UN Security
Council, and you push it as far as it
will go until you can't push it any
further cuz of China and Russia.
That's what you do.
You make the argument on the world
stage. You push that forward. You try to
pursue the legitimate avenue. And if it
is so, if the
the moral crime
is so abhorrent
that it must be acted upon
even without that authorization, then at
that point you act.
You You just decide you're going to go
do it.
You don't decide you're going to go do
it and then inform your European allies.
[__] that. No. You go through the UN.
Those uh potential outcomes were not
favorable. If they were actually
potentially way too destructive, he
would have maybe even just not done it
at all, which I would also support as a
decision. I'd rather this decision was
put in front of of the desk of someone
who can actually make that decision.
Which is why I would also trust a yes
from someone like Biden much more than
someone like Trump.
So, he understands all that, but he just
had to [__] pivot to this thing that
I got I don't know [__] why. Liberal
fascist, bro.
Meddling in other people's countries.
What? Like [__] Iran does. Like
Like that You you Well, Iran do it, too.
What are we saying, man?
What is that argument? What what what is
the argument there?
Where's the tweet? Where's the deep
tweet?
We're so back. We're so back.
You know, like Iran antagonizes not just
countries in the region. They don't just
murder people in volume.
>> Guys, so you know Iran's really bad.
Guys, so you know Iran's really bad.
That means [__] international law.
Thank you guys. I mean, Iraq, Lebanon,
Syria.
It's also it's also America. They've
they've attacked Americans. Even just in
this in this decade, just like the
Well, a load of bollocks. Maybe leave
that one out.
Maybe leave that one out.
Not quite as compelling that last one.
Look at a few years ago, there have been
Iranian attempts to murder journalists
who are from the diaspora who disagree
with them, who oppose the regime. But,
whatever.
That's besides the point.
>> Okay, stop. Yes, that's that's my
position.
>> like so not It's like so [__] Such
a non-sequitur. Guys, so you know who
What? You you think it's wrong to [__]
around in other people's countries
without consulting the international
community or going through the UN
Security Council to doing it [__]
anything?
Uh well, don't you know that uh Iran's
really bad? Cool, man.
Awesome. Wow, high-level stuff.
All those books doing you good, clearly
Liner Box. All those [__] books doing
you don't know you a lot of good.
Okay. Yes.
If that makes you and your little
[__] guy feel happy, yes.
Every single thing.
This complete up this entire operation
is [__] based.
If only for the fact
If if only it could be done with Hillary
Clinton's head on the planes.
Okay. I mean basically, no? [__] me.
You're like fine with these unilateral
strikes. That seems to be the case.
That's what you're saying.
As long as it's planned well.
Like yeah, you think the other people
should be informed, but ultimately it's
just the US president's decision they
just do it.
It should be treated like you're a Nazi.
Jesus.
>> And Liner Box belongs in the Tower of
London cuz he's a [__] traitor. Nice.
>> And Liner Box sees that
and feels upset about that. I'm not
going to be like, I'm so confused as to
why Liner Box is upset by this thing
that I've just said. Now, Liner Box will
say this.
What is Liner
>> Box about something that ends up being
true?
He'll sit there and bemoan and act like
the [__] victim over the fact that
lefties are upset with him over it.
And then
>> think a single lefty is upset with me
over this. They just see an opportunity.
That's all that is.
That's that's all that is. I don't think
they're upset by it. Especially since
this clip I remember it was me just
initially saying I'm going to need more
than the word of the IRGC the the
Iranian state, which I maintain which I
still maintain. The of course
Literally, does he even listen? Does
this [__] [__] have ears, bro? It's
crazy.
Yeah, I said I don't have a problem with
saying that, but obviously the way you
said it is going to set people off.
When you see a
a girl's school get bombed, you go
they're [__] liars.
It's going to set people off. And I
don't think they all just see an
opportunity. Yes, they are engaging a
lot of the time with motivated reason.
They already hate you. They already have
screwed you, etc. etc. etc.
But no, they do see it and get mad.
I think they do genuinely see it and get
mad at you. I think people I object do
genuinely like hate you and get mad at
you.
Of course he would need more than their
word. Like cuz they do lie. They lie
quite habitually, actually.
Um
but
This whole clip actually even includes
me getting more information like within
what? Like a like minutes? Whatever.
>> When Hasan does this exact same thing to
Israel, he'll spend a week talking about
it. What? Give me one example, you
[__] emaciated little [__] Like give
me one example. I'm sorry, what? An
example of Hasan getting a breaking news
story about some great tragedy and then
raking him over the coals because he
says I need more information cuz I don't
trust this initial source. Like what if
it's like
like
I don't consider actually Israel to be
an equivalent to the [__] Iranian
state.
>> Exactly. So there we go. Dude, he
literally can't even do the cope. He
can't even do the cope cuz I know I I
can't go and find the clip. I I won't
even know what such. But I know I
know he has made
almost word for word this exact point,
okay?
Let me try and formulate it. Let me try
and formulate it. Like cuz I've heard
this so many times. It's what How's it
How does the argument go?
It's some [__] about like Israel being
like a
uh relatively trustworthy, you know,
accountable
Western, you know, like liberal
army type whatever the [__] they say
about it.
And that if you just it it knee-jerk
referring to the IDF or Israel as liars
is anti-Semitic. I'm almost certain I am
almost certain.
And listen.
Maybe maybe we do something. Maybe I do
like
I will bet a load of bucks. I will bet a
load of bucks and then we'll get someone
some [__]
sketso to comb through his thoughts and
see if they can find it. If they can't
find it
I'll pay up. But I'm pretty certain
Learned a Box has made that argument. I
am like pretty certain
he's done that.
I I I would
you know.
I'd be pretty confident on that. I cuz I
have heard that argument
so many times hearing people talk about
Hasan.
And I don't listen to that many people
talk about it.
a lot of reasons. It's harder to
suppress information within Israel than
it is in Iran.
Um
but even if he just said he needs more
information or like I don't trust these
lying [__] or whatever. Again, okay,
yeah, I could be wrong. It could be that
he's never made that argument. It could
be Learned a Box literally has never
made that argument. And I'll say sorry
Learned a Box. That's totally an untrue
I have an untrue interpretation of you.
But I do I do believe he has made
arguments on those lines. I do I do
believe that pretty firmly.
Same clip shows you like 30 seconds
later he's got more information and he's
adjusting his perspec- Yeah, I would
rake him over the coals for that. Give
me one example, bro. [__] hell.
It's incoherent. How much would you bet
on that? I I'd bet like 25 quid, you
know, it's it's a respectable but small
bet, you know, enough enough money for
it to be real money but
not anything that's going to cause me
any problems, you know.
hearing. It's like the most [__]
entitled behavior from these [__]
losers. The zogged out Ethan Klein dick
riding crew
all have the most [__] attitudes in the
world. This is the thing, man. It's like
it's totally reasonable to make the
statement, I don't trust the state media
of the theocratic dictatorship. But the
sparking out the moment you see this
article makes you look uh [__] and
inhuman. And you must recognize that cuz
you would recognize it in anyone else.
Um and that's why you're going to get
flagged for this.
I just I just I just don't I don't know
about people like when do I when have I
popped off at someone for getting a
breaking news statement that gets So so
he can't even present it accurately. He
keeps saying that it's
we're getting a breaking news statement
and not immediately believing it. That's
not what you're being criticized for,
Helen. That's not what anyone's got a
[__] issue with.
Obviously the way you reacted to it,
dude. It's the knee-jerk, they're
[__] liars and not like
looking into it, right? It's like if
you're going to And he does look into it
later, but if you're going to do that,
you need to it's like
people want to see you immediately ready
to find the truth.
That's what they want. You can handle
the knee-jerk, they're liars if you're
ready to immediately jump into finding
the truth.
Otherwise,
if you want to avoid people getting mad,
it's best to just go
oh, I want another source to corroborate
that first.
As opposed to doing they're [__]
liars.
Because you can imagine Israel says
there's 40 beheaded babies,
Hasan goes,
they're [__] liars.
I don't believe that. They're [__]
liars.
And you might be like, woah, Hasan.
I mean, that was untrue, the 40 beheaded
babies thing. It was actually like What
was it What was it?
40 children died.
One was beheaded, whatever. I can't
remember. I can't remember what the the
actual story and the being of that.
But you get the point either way.
I don't know how much of that was Israel
lying and how much of that was like
Biden
brain deterioration. Ethan took it as
fact and went after Hasan for not
agreeing. Maybe that's what my brain is
like pulling up in the back of my head.
There are actually two minors killed in
that kibbutz, it says Ryan Beard.
I don't know. I don't know how true that
is. I don't know the truth of any of
this stuff. I don't live in Gaza attack.
But yeah, I think that might be what my
uh brain is pulling up. It is from all
that time we go.
I feel like I must have seen Lonnie Box
cover that.
Someone find that. There's got to be
Lonnie Box coverage
of
Ethan going after Hasan for not
believing that, right? I feel like if I
would have heard him say it, it would be
there.
an authoritarian state media
and not trusting it until they see more
information. When have I ever attacked
someone for that particular
Whatever. What what Wow, yeah, Lonnie
Box. That's what I was saying in that
clip.
Is it you've attacked Hasan for
literally the exact specific thing that
happened in your exact case.
Not the general same thing.
You know, the the knee-jerk reaction
calling the other sides
you know
media a liar over some tragedy and
spurring it about on stream.
Like I'm the bad faith one, guys. I'm
the bad faith cuz I say liberal fascist
and mean words while I'm talking about
him.
When these are the arguments, this is
the engagement. The third time stamp
about me.
Oh, wow.
The Middle East and North Africa.
>> can't get me off his mind.
Okay, we'll fight about the Hutch thing
later. Stop bitching, chat. Sorry, my
chat's bitching. Stop bitching. What are
they bitching about?
>> to talk about interesting [__] first.
God damn.
>> Is it your chat is it the Queenman Just
School Infiltrators?
>> chat. My chat's bitching because they
want me to fight you about Hutchinson,
but I wanted to get through the Epstein
stuff first.
>> Okay, I did not expect Queenman to Dude,
this guy literally just
totally raped. I don't talk about this
guy.
I do not cover Destiny.
When was the last time I covered Destiny
in any serious capacity?
I barely even retweet [__] about him.
Let alone make actual comments myself.
It's like so crazy.
dominate the stream that much, but okay.
So,
anyways, um Adnan Khashoggi is an arms
dealer. He deals in the Middle East and
North Africa.
>> For just to be [snorts] clear, I did
that segment that I did earlier today, I
just wanted to show you guys kind of why
I'm
>> [laughter]
>> a little bit disconnected from that
group now. Like I just I don't think
there's anything
valuable going on there.
Wow. I think I spent a bit too long
thinking that there was some kind of
good faith critique or whatever that I
could get something from or
but no, just sounds like
>> that's another another community. 109
online community is one of the most
people that has fallen out with through
no fault of his own.
Through no fault of his own. Yet another
door closed, guys. Yet another door
closed.
Yet another friendship group lost.
Yet another group on the internet that
[__] hates him.
Like I don't even hate him. I don't know
why I'm saying that, but
you know what I mean?
It's like, bro, get a [__] grip. Not
everyone can be bad faith, okay? I
understand the only person who's not bad
faith is Destiny. I get it, man. I see.
Destiny and PeacesGo
and Hutch are the only people in the
world who aren't bad faith. Those are
the only people you can have a
conversation with. Okay, I see. No
problem, man.
No problem. Like what else am I supposed
to take from this? These [__]
retards, these borderline
I don't even want to say it.
All just want to talk to each other.
They just don't want to circle jerk with
like the same other three [__]
liberal fascists that that agree with
them, you know? They they just want that
endlessly.
Everyone outside of that is bad faith.
Every conservative is bad faith. Every
lefty is bad faith. And every
anti-Israel lib is bad faith.
Actually, every everyone who isn't
an Israel dick riding
uh
copyright false copyright strike
malicious copyright lawsuit
doxing supporting
pedophile lover
Everyone else who isn't that is bad
faith. If you don't If you're not down
with pedophiles
and you're not down with Israel
and you're not down with
[__]
Well, whatever else they're down with,
bro. Whatever else they're down with.
Then you're bad faith.
It's so [__] absurd, bro.
Like total [__] wank. Uh
Uh but that's okay. They can do what
they do.
Hope it makes them happy. Yeah,
vein bursting on Linea Rosa's head as he
tries not to call me anti-Semitic for
the entire segment. [__] this [__]
window. Hey.
Cuz this is what makes me happy. Is I
can get this
window to go back into the sub windows.
Why is it not doing that? Why have they
disconnected?
What the [__]
What?
There we go. Okay.
There. All right.
He's a part of the Iran-Contra affair
where Reagan and Oliver North take
weapons, they sanction bust, they sell
weapons They travel to Israel because
you can't fly directly to
Well, here's the reason why they say
they'll have a conversation with me is
bad faith is because they're like
Well, you're just going to You're just
going to lie to try and win. And how can
you ever do that? How can you Why would
you ever do that? You're in a losing
position. I'm I'm being honest. And I
can't I can't win being honest if you're
willing to just lie
or not engage properly. You know, if if
you're going to
like some you know, total queer loser
[__] reprobate scum [__] subhuman
like Nick might have a conversation
where he just sits there and goes, "Oh
my god, you just really think you really
think
you really think
Oh my god, you really that dude, this
looks so bad." the whole time. You might
not want to talk to someone that's doing
that.
Cuz it's [__] insufferable.
And it's just like
designed to
make you look bad and then look good.
So, you might
not want to talk to someone that's just
going to do that.
Because they can just frame you that way
to an audience.
And you just lose. You just get raped.
However,
you should be able to at least point out
why it's bad faith. Explain how it's bad
faith.
How am I being bad faith
when I interpret a statement that the
statement, "I would support this from
anyone else." as you saying roughly
these actions from a different person
you would be in favor of.
You have to explain how that's a bad
faith interpretation. You can't just go
bad faith, bad faith, bad faith at
everything. You have to explain why.
by Iran. Um Jeffrey Epstein facilitates
this through with Adnan Khashoggi and
they sell the weapons to Iran. They take
the cash, they put it in a black ops
slush fund that then runs guns and drugs
in Central and South America for counter
communist operations in Central and
South America. Okay.
Okay. Then Jeffrey Epstein
well that's actually really important,
but I want to add something else about
Adnan Khashoggi. He also facilitated
deals and there's a picture of him
facilitating arms deals in West and
South Africa as well via something
called the Safari Club which was a
financial and arms trafficking export
Free booting Destiny so his audience
gets to watch their favorite streamer.
Very nice. Very nice.
I guess he's talking about me there,
though.
So, wow.
What's it Let's see this clip. Let's see
this clip. Let's watch this clip for
like and retweet it. You can tell me if
you think this guy is like um
good faith critic or not, but
>> like that's not necessarily true. When
you when you analyze [clears throat]
that
>> crazy. I literally can't take it. It
makes me gag. It makes me gag hearing
this F-slur say this [__] Is this a
good faith critic? Is he good Is this a
good faith critic?
What do you mean by that?
I'm saying what I think.
What does good J Stool can do this no
problem.
I'm saying what I think.
What does good faith and bad faith mean
other than you say what you think
and don't lie about what the other
person thinks.
That's what I'm doing.
Do I say it in a mean way?
Yes.
Do I use personal attacks? Yes. Is that
bad faith? I wasn't aware it is. I I I
was not aware of that. If that's the
case,
I was not aware of it.
My understanding was that this was an
entertainment medium.
And if someone wanted to get dry,
reliable political analysis,
they would read a [__] article.
And my job
was to present my thoughts, opinions,
and information I've collected
in an entertaining way.
Oftentimes inflammatory to attract
attention.
Like me and Chud can do this no problem.
Me and J Stool can do this no problem.
Then you get people like Lauren Southern
Dick the Ori or Hutch. They're being bad
faith to me. They're being bad faith to
me. They're being toxic and bad faith to
me.
It's a [__] live stream, dude. It's a
[__] live It doesn't have to be the
end of the world, bro.
It doesn't destroy the criticism that
someone's making personal attacks in
between. And it shouldn't.
It's the [__] internet. It's a dagger
in my neck. He said I put a dagger in my
neck. My friend's accused of rape and
you put a dagger in my neck.